[Musique]
saurez-vous trouver les easter egg ses
références cachées
les réalisateurs de cette nouvelle web
série sont passionnés de cinéma de manga
ou encore de jeux vidéo
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup d'enfants
ce de boeuf que j'aime beaucoup et
l'adhérence à je ne sais tu pas que
j'aime beaucoup c'est chez moi
tranquille je les ai bien évidemment les
derniers essais du pauvre sa galère sur
l'appel des autorités dans les noms des
personnages et plein de références dans
les titres aussi c'est vrai que pas mal
de dommage parce qu'on peut dire à moi
je vais en tout cas clairement je me
suis inspiré des choses que de trafic
d'organes et des références mais pas
seulement
easter egg c'est aussi l'histoire de
deux collègues en compétition six
épisodes de 5 minutes tourné à saint
quentin en yvelines et affronter le
fleury ils sont onze à participer au
projet professionnel ou amateur
[Musique]
nous avions ce que tu as un bon moment
on a fait pas mal de choses ensemble
moi je suis photographe professionnel
sur fontenay le fleury donc bien
forcément tous cas l'image et du coup on
a parlé de ça
je le dis bah écoute moi je suis face à
un tour parce que tout ce que j'ai dit
est que vanité qui c'est-y qui commande
qui va aussi du côté des professionnels
de la finance et plein de projets en
sont elles la mise en ligne des épisodes
est prévue toutes les deux semaines
les références tu trouveras